[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID TU: Hey, it's David Tu,
and welcome back to "What's
New in Networking,"
where we cover, well,
what's new in networking.
Today, I'll provide
some new updates
for the Network Intelligence
Center, so let's dive right in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Networks are at the
foundation of an environment.
You need a pane of
glass that can provide
a multitude of tools to
troubleshoot, diagnose,
and monitor your environment.
The Network Intelligence Center
provides that single console
for managing Google Cloud
network visibility, monitoring,
verification, and optimization.
Today, there are currently
four modules in the Network
Intelligence Center--
network topology, connectivity
tests, performance dashboard,
and firewall insights.
Today, we'll be covering
new enhancements
for the connectivity test and
the performance dashboard.
Diving right in,
connectivity test
is a configuration
and route analyzer
that lets you diagnose
connectivity issues in your VPC
network due to a
misconfiguration
or due to missing routes.
When analyzing network
configurations,
connectivity test uses
an abstract state machine
to model how a VPC network
should process packets.
Google Cloud
processes the packet
in several logical steps.
Previously, connectivity test
was purely a configuration
analyzer.
With the launch of dynamic
reachability verification,
we introduced live
data plane analysis.
Dynamic verification
tests connectivity
by sending multiple trace
packets from the source
endpoint to the destination.
The dynamic verification
results show
you the number of
probes sent, the number
of probes that successfully
reached the destination,
and a reachability status.
The status is determined
based on how many probes
were successfully delivered.
Reachability is more than 95%.
Unreachable is 0%.
And partially reachable
is between 0% and 95%.
In addition to showing how
many packets were successfully
delivered, dynamic
verification also
shows median and 95th percentile
one-way latency information.
The last topic today will be
the performance dashboard.
Performance dashboard
gives you the visibility
into the performance of
your project's resources,
as well as the performance
of the entire Google Cloud
network.
It will provide you with packet
loss and latency details.
So how does it work?
Performance dashboard
runs workers
on physical hosts
that house your VMs.
These workers insert and
receive probe packets
that run on the same
network as your traffic.
Because the workers run on
the physical host and not
on the VMs, these workers
do not consume VM resources
and the traffic is not
visible to your VMs.
What about latency?
For latency, latency is
measured by TCP packets.
Based on the sample of
your actual traffic,
latency is calculated
as the time that
elapsed between sending
the TCP sequence number
and receiving the
corresponding ACK that
contains network RTT and
TCP stack-related delay.
The UI shows latency
at the median of all
the relevant measurements.
In the project performance
view, performance dashboard
shows packet loss
and latency for zones
where you have Compute Engine
resources for your project.
This release introduces
a performance dashboard
for all of Google Cloud.
The dashboard presents the
overall Google Cloud metrics
for each possible
Google Cloud zone pair.
It displays the current
status of Google Cloud Network
and lets you compare performance
across all of Google Cloud
to the performance
observed in your projects.
Similar to project
view, performance
will be shown via summary
charts and heat maps
for both packet
loss and latency.
And you have the ability to
review six weeks of history.
So that's all we have for
this episode of "What's
New in Networking."
Check out the links below to
learn more about the Network
Intelligence Center, and stay
tuned for the next episode
of "What's New in Networking."
[MUSIC PLAYING]